you have survived into late adulthood
into well technically buyers and it's
early adulthood but you know for you
know going back to human evolution
making it 24 you did it you survived one
of the most dangerous periods early
early life
clearly whatever it is you did worked do
not reject those things because you
could die and so there was an
evolutionary pressure for us to become
what we are and then adhere to it
additionally there's an evolutionary
pressure to reopen our minds in the
middle of our Lives hence a midlife
crisis people start adapting and trying
new things for a reason for for these
reasons so if you go to someone who's 25
or older maybe 40. and tell them with
proof their worldview is incorrect it
will cause them physical and emotional
pain and they will not accept it they
will get angry because when you get
emotional your logic shuts down breaking
through to these people is very very
difficult